we've already set up an 18 billion pound
program for businesses one of the most
generous in Europe and today we're
announcing a further five and a half
billion pound program for next year
lower because gas prices have come right
down but I am concerned that even even
though wholesale prices are lower number
four Putin invaded Ukraine a lot of
businesses have yet to see the benefit
of that in the bills they actually pay
so I'm also asking off gem to do an
investigation to look into the market to
see whether it's functioning in the way
it should the the package you've
outlined is considerably less generous
than its predecessor many businesses
saying they might go to the wall as a
result are you happy to see jobs lost
and some businesses shut down simply
because you're trying to save a bit of
money
no and that's not what we're doing and
no government can continue to subsidize
indefinitely higher energy prices but
what we can do which matters to all
those businesses is to bring down
inflation and that means we have to be
responsible with public finances but at
the same time today we're announcing
five and a half billion pounds that's
nearly a penny on income tax for every
taxpayer in the country to help
businesses through this difficult period
and and on inflation strikes there's
another big story that is associated
with that will the treasury be able to
find money to offer one-off payments to
help resolve the NHS strikes well talks
have started today and they're carrying
on this week and I don't think it'd be
right for me to talk about any
individual aspect of those except to say
that I think it's good that both sides
are talking to each other we're
understanding the concerns that each
other has and from the government's
point of view we recognize the hard work
that public sector workers are doing in
all different parts of the public sector
sector but we don't want to agree to a
settlement that would further fuel
inflation or be unaffordable so we need
to find that middle ground and I hope
that's what happens with these talks and
finally there's been an investigation by
Sky News and tortoise media the
Westminster account Center transparency
or payments to uh to MPS on that do you
think there is enough transparency when
it comes to the money that MPS are
receiving they've made over 17 million
pounds in total in outside earnings this
Parliament over 15 million of that went
to Tory MPS more than 250 000 to you
alone is that why you won't reform the
system well in terms of the earnings
that came to me they were all given to
charity so that's the decision that I
personally made
um I think it's good that you do these
investigations we have one of the most
transparent systems in the world and
people should know what income their MPS
are receiving what donations they've
received for their political campaigns
and I think it's really helpful that you
have put all that information together
and then people can make their judgment
at the ballot boxes as to whether their
MPS are behaving in the way that they
want any reforms as a result of this
well I think we have a lot of
transparency which allows you to put
together the database that you've put
together and I think if people have any
concerns then they will Express those at
The Ballot Box